نظم زعماء تحالف الشعب المعارض في تركيا
مهرجانات انتخابيه في مدينه اسطنبول مع
اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه
المقرره في الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري
والقاز علماء تحالف الشعب من المقرر ان
يعقد تحالف الجمهور المكون من حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم وحزب الحركه القوميه
واحزاب اخرى مهرجانات الانتخابيه في
اسطنبول مساء اليوم
[موسيقى]
وقد ادلى حتى الان نحو مليون وخمسمائه الف
شخص من الناخبين الاتراك المقيمين في
الخارج باصواتهم في الانتخابات العامه
والرئاسيه التصويت في البعثات الدبلوماسيه
التركيه في الخارج يستمر حتى التاسع من
هذا الشهر بينما يستمر في المعابر
الحدوديه والمطارات حتى الرابعه عشر من
الشهر من الشهر الجاري نفسه